already getting pumped for the arrival
of Vin Diesel's new cinematic universe
we've got him rounded up the best rumors
and spoilers the Internet has to offer
these are just some of the leaked
details surrounding the bloodshot movie
according to geeks worldwide the new
bloodshot is going to be something of a
take on the classic revenge tale
Vin Diesel plays ray garrison a marine
who after he and his wife are murdered
is resurrected as a super soldier when
Garrison's erased memories return he
sets out to exact revenge on the man
responsible for his and his wife's
deaths bloodshot's us based on a comic
book from publisher Valiant Comics which
may explain why at first glance the
character seems reminiscent of other
comic heroes who have been adapted to
the big screen such as Deadpool Winter
Soldier and Wolverine but form editor in
chief of valiant and co-creator of the
character Bob Layton assured deadlines
in 2018 that this is a unique project he
insisted that he and bloodshot writer
Kevin Van Hook worked very very hard to
give bloodshot a voice that was very
different from those other characters
Layton also said bloodshot's filmmakers
of a processor film with the
understanding that audiences know comic
films he explained the filmmakers were
embracing the current movie-going
audiences knowledge of comic book
storytelling and have produced something
very fresh and subversive to the genre
at the beginning of 2018 dmg
entertainment a six billion dollar media
company which co-produced 2012's looper
and 2013 Iron Man 3 took full control of
valiant entertainment dmg founder Dan
Mintz announced our priority is to build
upon valiance vast universe of
characters from a filmmakers perspective
I'm excited to immerse valiance fans
well beyond the stories we tell
cinematically from publishing to gaming
to theme parks and beyond dmg and
valiant originally set up a partnership
deal in 2015 which included plans for
both film and television so it isn't
surprising that bloodshot has tabbed as
only the beginning of a future franchise
for the company deadline reported that
dmg valiant and Sony had made plans for
a five film series that would include
valiance bloodshot and Harbinger as well
as a shared crossover film called
Harbinger was in a 2017 interview with
den of geek newly tapped bloodshot
screenwriter Erik Hazara spoke on the
importance of not relying on related
films or sequels when approaching a
franchise film by Zura who's also been
hired to write the Harbinger script said
he wanted to focus on the films as
though they were self-contained stories
he
my goal was to make a great Harbinger
script and a great bloodshot script and
if audiences love those stories and we
were honored enough to come back and
revisit those characters great in his
interview his deadline Bob Layton
expanded on the idea that bloodshot
wouldn't just be another comic franchise
film saying they're really focusing on
Vince character and it really seems to
be a more character-driven movie rather
than just a lot of big explosions
explaining how comics films tend to rely
too heavily on third acts fight scenes
Layton said the key to a good superhero
film it's to keep the focus on the
character that's supposed to making it a
quote giant rollercoaster ride in July
2018 sources told key collector Comics
that two villains would appear in
bloodshot the first to be identified was
a computer obsessed axe he made his
debut in Harbinger issue three his
thirst for technology would eventually
lead him to seek old blood shot in order
to steal his nanites enhanced blood The
Wrap reported that Fantastic Four's Toby
Kebbell will be playing the character at
the same time The Wrap confirmed that
Game of Thrones actor
Johanna Stoker Johanna CERN has been
added to the cast as a second villain
although who exactly he would be playing
was still unknown according to IMDB
however Johanna stone is listed as
portraying a character named Nick Barris
since has been established at the film's
premise will differ from the comics it's
still hard to say who exactly Nick
Barris is in the bloodshot universe when
the wrap first reported up in diesel was
in the talks to star in bloodshot in
January 2018 the film had been described
as an r-rated take on the comic
adaptation that will be totally and
aesthetically influenced by high-concept
sci-fi blockbusters of the late 80s
including Robocop Terminator and Total
Recall
that's our ratings seem to mean that
bloodshot we'll be following in the
footsteps of other recent
non-traditional comic films like Logan
and Deadpool
Oh Oh
Chanin ah that's not good
more recently however I looked as though
bloodshot could potentially be going for
a pg-13 rating as noted by discussing
film which shared the film's first full
synopsis in March 2019 a pg-13 rating
would allow Sony to reach a wider
audience as well as a consistent wider
market for the studio's planned valiant
cinematic universe since the character
is known for its hard our persona the
decision to give the movie a more
family-friendly edge may wind up
backfiring for Sony for fans familiar
with the bloodshot comic series ray
Garrison's look is prettier mistakable
pale skin black hair red eyes he also
has a penchant for running around
without a shirt on so when Vin Diesel
posted the first image from the film to
his Instagram account in july 2019 it
wasn't exactly what fans were expecting
the image which shows a pretty regular
looking diesel in the camouflage jacket
aviator shades and without any hair is a
far cry from the bloodshot of the comics
diesel captioned the pic ray garrison is
a central character in the valiant comic
universe and for me personally one of
the most complex characters I've been
fortunate enough to play hope to make
you proud hashtag bloodshot of course
it's entirely possible that this first
image is of Ray before it's forced on my
procedure and that's in the coming
months we'll be able to see more of the
character from Valiants pages but it's
certainly a start check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
you